yet another paper this one published in
a mainstream place it's still in in
pre-print it's not published it hasn't
been peer-reviewed but by reputable
mainstream academic it's called
serious adverse events of special
interest following mrna vaccination and
randomized trials
the communicating author is peter doshi
who
boy i think is
uh
editor
i've forgotten now i don't have it in my
notes that are on screen right now
at
i want to say the british medical
journal although i'm not positive about
that the results in the abstract which
is the summary written by the authors
of of the paper of the research they
have done
pfizer and modernity mrna covet 19
vaccines were associated with an
increased risk of serious adverse events
of special interest with an absolute
risk increase of 10.1 and 15.1 per 10
000 vaccinated over placebo based lines
of 72.6 and 42.2
uh 95 confidence interval et cetera et
cetera
combined the mrna vaccines were
associated with an absolute risk
increase of serious adverse events of
special interest of twelve point five
per ten thousand ninety-five percent
confidence interval two point one to
twenty two point nine
the excess risk of serious adverse
events of special interest surpassed the
risk reduction for copenhagen
hospitalization relative to the police
relative to the placebo group in both
pfizer and madonna trials 2.3 and 6.4
per 10 000 participants respectively
so in
plain english
what they found by going and looking at
the data in the
uh
that that advisor in moderna finally
released
is that the
risks from these vaccines the risks of
serious adverse events and they describe
how those are defined and they would
find pretty carefully and very much the
same between fives and marina
the instance of serious adverse events
is higher than the benefits
from the vaccines as measured by release
bradys reduced
hospitalizations
that is consistent with all sorts of
things we're seeing of course uh this is
a paper that is due to be published in a
major journal
by a lot of
you know a lot of big names who are you
know have not been have have not been
platformed have not been cancelled for
saying such things this is the paper you
can see they've
put in big grid print across the back
across you know pre-print not
peer-reviewed but as we've talked about
before
you've you've a got what seven authors
on here who effectively each other's
peers who are here reviewing it and lots
of other people who know what they're
doing who have reviewed this effectively
uh but because most people who aren't
scientists hear peer review as the the
pseudonym of what it means on good
science the fact that's not
peer-reviewed is going to be used to
uh to
dismiss it dismiss it so this paper is
uh a new take on somewhat old data it
says much the same thing that many
people have been saying in a slightly
different form
there has been as far as i've seen not a
peep in the mainstream media about it
i saw it i don't remember how originally
but then i also saw it covered in phil
harper's substance
and this is rubber malone as well okay
robert malone also talked about it
and you know it's this it's the same as
the usual suspects you know including us
talking about these things over and over
and over again and
one has to wonder
what
why what is going on so sort of
simultaneous with with this
this being out recently we have
uh zach if you would show
the first i'm gonna ask you to show the
three things that i sent to you we've
got first in washington state wait wait
can we go back and say a thing or two
about this paper if we're going to move
on well this is all connected but sure
um one thing i want to say is that
inherent to what this paper presents is
a conservatism about the conclusion
right really the conclusion is already
the cost of those vaccinations exceeds
the benefit
the likelihood so because they define
serious adverse events the likelihood
that there is subclinical stuff that has
been caused by these vaccinations but
that has not um
unfolded in a serious event yet things
that could be that could remove decades
from people's lives right those things
are very likely to make the picture much
much worse the longer the time period
over which you evaluate them and so
effectively this paper is saying
within a year we have already reached a
level of adverse events that exceeds any
benefit we've seen the chances that the
best actually i think it was pfizer who
only tracked it for a month after
one of one of them i don't remember
which one was i think it was fisa that
actually didn't even track for the whole
year they just tracked for a month after
the second dose the vaccination i think
right um
in any case the point is over a short
period of time the amount of harm done
by the vaccines is already exceeding the
benefit done but because we know the
benefit declines and the harm we don't
know what it does long term but the
chances that it does serious harm and
then none is very very low
so the point is the picture is likely to
be much worse than they present
absolutely so your point i didn't
understand what you meant at first by
conservative here
it is important it is important for
scientists to
convey a conservative interpretation of
their own results
so that even if they think they're
seeing something extremely strong
they stay within the you know the
conservative bounds of what it might
mean which increases the chances that
what they're saying is true although it
may
may well under sell under describe what
is actually true and so there are at
least at least i guess you've described
maybe three ways
that these results here are likely to be
conservative
that
the benefits of the vaccines decline
over time
the costs of the vaccines will increase
over time
and
and therefore a short time period of
measurement
will uh
appear to make the benefits be higher
than they actually are and also appear
to underweigh the costs
and then you also have what was the
third one
um i can't remember at the moment what
the third way that it was conservative
um
well it's conservative in multiple ways
i think one we didn't mention was
that
were you to do an all-cause mortality
over a very long period of time you
would catch lots of little harms that
don't show up in particular adverse
events yeah actually that's related to
the one i had in my head which i think
you did allude to before which is that
they have specified
in order to be very careful in order to
make it maximally quantitative
uh
serious adverse events and that means
that anything that is not designated as
serious or anything that is subclinical
in any way or indeed again this is
related to the first points um anything
that has a delayed effect is unlikely to
be captured here
right and i will also point out that
those of us in the
heterodox scientific and and medical
community are very
concerned about the degree to which the
aggressiveness of this campaign
and the focus on vaccinating everybody
irrespective of whether or not their
particular jeopardy suggested it might
be of value to them has the collateral
effect of making it very hard to figure
out how much harm was done by the
vaccines because it makes the control
group that much
smaller and harder to identify right
[Music]